[Música]
[Aplausos]
Bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
de France 24 que los invita a dar una
vuelta al mundo de la mano de nuestra
red de periodistas en Guatemala miles de
militares retirados han comenzado una
serie de protestas exigiendo una
indemnización que les prometió Alejandro
yamatey durante su campaña presidencial
hace tres años un partido derecha hizo
una propuesta para que a cada uno de
ellos les fueran entregados más de 15
mil dólares con motivo de su servicio
durante la época del conflicto entre el
estado y la guerrilla sin embargo años
más tarde la propuesta aún no ha sido
sancionada en el congreso y los
veteranos exigen que se les cumplan el
siguiente es un reportaje de nuestros
corresponsales Aurora bayod y Andrés
Suárez Jaramillo nosotros somos los
Héroes de la patria señores
gustados frente al congreso de Guatemala
los veteranos militares exigen que se
les retribuya con dinero la guerra que
pelearon durante 36 años y que dejó más
de 200.000 Muertos Pues fíjate que el
señor presidente nos ofreció pagarlos
nuestros derechos de que del conflicto
armado interno pero hasta este día él no
nos ha puesto la cara
al no contar con una pensión los
veteranos de guerra se aferraron a la
promesa política del presidente
Alejandro yamatey de recibir un Bono
económico un proyecto de ley que lleva
tres años sin avanzar en el congreso
entonces queremos que se nos aprueba los
derechos que estamos peleando
Arcadio de Jesús oliva Pérez es uno de
los 98.000 ex militares guatemaltecos
que exige la indemnización de más de 15
mil dólares
actualmente vive en una aldea rural de
Guatemala donde aún conserva las fotos
de cuando era un joven que reclutaron a
la fuerza para pelear en el monte los
años más cruentos de la guerra
en la guerra si no mata uno lo matan a
uno verdad Pero de que me defendí en
ciertos momentos con mi arma si lo hice
otro de los recuerdos que conserva son
las botas de patrullero
el ponerme ahora las botas Pues para mí
no es que se diga una una alegría un
orgullo porque la verdad
los beneficiados de la defensa de la
prat de la patria
eran los cabezones del ejército
con 58 años Arcadio tiene cuatro hijos
nueve nietos un bisnieto y ninguna
pensión a la vista ala Qué rico
motivos para luchar por un Bono de
guerra que posiblemente no va a obtener
y que ante la Carta Magna de Guatemala
es inconstitucional
[Música]
vamos ahora a Francia porque las huelgas
de los trabajadores en las refinerías de
total energys han terminado por producir
una escasez de combustible que ha
terminado por afectar a cerca de un
tercio de las estaciones de servicio del
país generando largas filas y
frustración en muchos de los
automovilistas en medio de las ganancias
récord de las compañías de hidrocarburos
debido a los altos precios de la energía
ahora los empleados exigen un aumento
salarial de por lo menos el 10%. el
gobierno insiste en que no hay motivos
para el pánico sin embargo también hace
un llamado a la responsabilidad informe
de nuestros colegas de fostervisión y de
Olivier
una fila Aparentemente interminable de
vehículos a primera hora de la mañana
del sábado en París algunos
automovilistas pasaron horas parados con
la esperanza de llenar sus depósitos
me levanté a las 4 de la mañana para ir
a buscar gasolina
tras una larga espera hubo alivio aunque
las existencias eran limitadas
no es la gasolina sino el tiempo que
estoy perdiendo en el coche
la búsqueda de combustible continuó
durante toda la noche la escasez
provocada por las huelgas en las
refinerías ha afectado a una de cada
cinco gasolineras en Francia el norte
del país está especialmente afectado
como en esta estación de servicio de
arras donde se está controlando la
entrada Cuánto tienes tres cuartos no se
puede no no
solo se permite la entrada a personas
con ocupaciones prioritarias algo que
los automovilistas parecen entender
los vehículos prioritarios tienen que
poder repostar y estar disponibles pero
incluso esta trabajadora que pudo llegar
a los surtidores está teniendo
dificultades
la estación que fue reabastecida el
viernes ya no tiene combustible
noche pero no había me dijeron que los
estaban reabasteciendo pero ya no hay
nada voy a probar en el surtidor de al
lado o en el otro o por ahí
el gobierno dice que no hay que entrar
en pánico pero los partidos de la
oposición y aseguran que no está
haciendo lo suficiente para resolver la
situación la fiscalía alemana abrió una
investigación por el presunto Sabotaje
que sufrieron los gasoductos nordstream
que pasan por el mar Báltico y que
produjeron enormes fugas de gas al
ambiente el hecho se produjo en momentos
en los que el país europeo se enfrenta a
una histórica de escasez de gas natural
y cuando ha tenido que renovar los
llamados a sus ciudadanos para que
reduzcan el consumo con el fin de evitar
cortes durante el invierno en medio de
esta situación crítica un pueblo en el
norte de bavi ha encontrado una forma
innovadora de mantener sus casas
calientes producen su propia
electricidad e incluso le sobra para
exportar como lo logran veámoslo en el
informe de Peter Hot Sierra
Desde la distancia grossbardorf puede
parecer un pueblo más de Alemania pero
si se mira de más cerca sus mil
habitantes obtienen casi toda su energía
de fuente renovables locales la pieza
maestra una red interconectada de calor
y electricidad alimentada por maíz
estiércol y residuos vegetales
esas plantas fermentan mediante
bacterias producen metano ese metano
impulsa un generador para generar
electricidad como cualquier motor
necesita refrigeración Y esa agua de
refrigeración calienta el pueblo
complementa esta red con cuatro Molinos
de viento y más de 8 hectáreas de
paneles solares El pueblo produce ahora
15 veces en la electricidad que necesita
con precios energéticos bajos un gran
atractivo
vienen empresas impuestos municipales y
sobre todo los jóvenes se encuentran
trabajo aquí y los jóvenes son el futuro
el modelo no puede aplicarse en todas
partes ni adoptarse de la noche a la
mañana Sin embargo puede proporcionar
independencia de los mercados
energéticos globales a las pequeñas
comunidades en un mundo inestable el fin
de la pandemia marcó el regreso del
turismo masivo a la capital catalana
este verano Y con él están también de
vuelta los carteristas Barcelona es una
de las ciudades europeas más afectadas
con cientos de robos reportados
semanalmente ante este creciente flagelo
Y ante la incapacidad de la policía para
frenarlo grupos de ciudadanos se
organizan patrullan en la ciudad para
advertir a los transeúntes disuadir a
los delincuentes e incluso frenarlos el
siguiente es un informe de
explícito y eloise levec
y la gente que colaboró estamos en
Barcelona en el metro estos carteristas
agarrados infraganti son llamados al
orden otra
vez
Estas imágenes fueron tomadas por Eliana
en su tiempo libre esta barcelonesa
recorre los pasillos del metro para
alertar a los pasajeros
señoras y señores vigilar vuestras
pertenencias vale
en la ciudad más visitado de España los
robos son habituales para proteger a los
usuarios Eliana ha creado una patrulla
formada por unos 50 vecinos conecta muy
bien el aeropuerto en 10 años Eliana ha
desarrollado todo un arsenal de métodos
para localizar y detener a los ladrones
esta línea es la mina para ellos
es el lenguaje corporal lo has visto
cómo miraba la mochila Has visto cómo se
hablan has visto que no van vigilando el
móvil Mira ellos van vigilando el pasaje
ellos no van a ir como vamos todos y el
agresor queda marcado durante 24 horas
de rojo y bueno esta bolsa que lleva el
móvil y aquí siempre va la cámara
encendida para poder pillar cualquier
intento de robo
cientos de vídeos que el colectivo
ciudadano publica en las redes sociales
publicamos en redes sociales porque
entendemos que esto es de interés
ciudadano o sea sus caras son de interés
ciudadano todos estos son carteristas
por su parte el sindicato mayoritario de
la policía catalana no ve con buenos
ojos esta brigada pero utilizan métodos
que no son legales no pueden utilizar
sprays de pimienta y menos en un área
como el transporte público un área
cerrada que puede ser peligrosa para
otros usuarios y usuarias y tampoco
evidentemente pueden grabar con con
ningún dispositivo móvil porque está
prohibido es ilegal
la policía Calcula que cada día se
producen unos 200 robos en la capital
catalana la exposición en la fundación
Louis Vuitton de París crea por primera
vez un diálogo visual artístico
sensorial y poético entre las obras de
Dos artistas excepcionales Claude con
sus nenúfares y Joan ambos dejaron su
huella no solo en su época sino también
en generaciones posteriores de pintores
el siguiente es un informe de nuestros
colegas de fonsberg y Olivia piso
nenúfares del Artista francés Claude
Money y la naturaleza orillas del sena
del estadounidense John mitchell Money y
mitchell y los Dos artistas se comparan
a menudo Aunque pintaron el momentos
diferentes para entender mejor por qué
volvamos atrás desde sus inicios
mitchell se dio a conocer por sus trazos
abstractos tuvo reconocimiento en Nueva
York que en los años 50 junto con otros
artistas abstractos como Jackson pollock
que querían reinventar radicalmente la
pintura Fue entonces cuando
redescubrieron los nenúfares de monet
fueron las últimas pinturas del Artista
francés cuando sufría ya de disminución
de la vista en sus primeras obras una
utilizaba la perspectiva que daba
volumen a su arte
pero sus nenúfares aparecen planos y
borrosos eso es lo que convirtió al
pintor francés en un pionero de la
abstracción según los expresionistas
estadounidenses
sí lo maneja
y todos los pintores expresionistas
abstractos americanos se compararon con
Club monet y se inspiraron
no ocultó esa influencia se instaló en
las orillas del sena a pocos kilómetros
de la casa de monet donde se inspiró en
un paisaje compartido por primera vez
esta exposición sitúa las obras de ambos
pintores una al lado de la otra Crean un
diálogo visual excepcional
queremos agradecer a café la mata por
prestarnos sus instalaciones para la
grabación de este programa ya ustedes
también Muchas gracias por seguir un
nuevo episodio de corresponsales nos
damos cita la próxima semana siga con
más información en francés 24.com
[Música]